let's bring in Dan bongino host of
unfiltered with Dan bongino to comment
on this Dan the upside down world of the
administration being most on inhumane to
illegals is the one claiming to be the
most Humane but the numbers don't lie
yeah I mean a couple of things first
Chris Hayes over at that other network
just ran into what Jesse calls uh Jesse
Waters calls the binder uh she's clearly
the I mean have you ever met someone so
unfit for a job her title is literally
White House spokesperson and she doesn't
want to speak to things it's like being
like the number three hitter on a
baseball team going you know what I
don't feel like stepping in the batter's
box not my thing well if it's not your
thing then don't play baseball she never
answers a question on anything I mean at
least saki would answer the question and
lie okay we get it like you know she's
very talented at lying I don't know if
that's a compliment or what but Kareem
Jean-Pierre is just really genuinely
awful at this job that that aside though
this is a very serious topic and I'm
glad you're covering it this morning I
was very excited when the producers uh
sent this over because this is our you
know my wife's a legal immigrant to this
country I came here with with her mother
I I don't like talking I get all choked
up talking about the story Rachel's
heard did Pete's heard it will you're
going to hear it now a little bit but
came here you know they came here
legally and my my mother-in-law man she
she busted her butt you know you
just in a Jackson Heights Apartment you
know heads tails the three her and her
three kids together and she came over
with ten dollars in her wallet you know
and then she got to meet uh you know
when she when when I brought her home a
a signed hat from president Trump and
she couldn't believe it she said you
know Danny I came here with nothing in
my wall now you're bringing me home a
hat signed by the president United
States like that's what immigration is
about and that's the Conservative
Republican position that gosh you know
we we're in most countries on Earth are
in the middle of a demographic Time Bomb
read that Wall Street Journal I bet
about China if you doubt me no but
there's not going to be anyone around to
care for the elderly in China we need
people but we need people wherever
you're from Mexico Asia Africa wherever
you're from the Caribbean we need you to
come here the right way because of what
will just addressed in those those
god-awful statistics fentanyl crossing
the border drugs crossing the border sex
trafficking at the border uh and I'll
tell you when I was a secret service
agent what people don't know is the same
mules who are bringing drugs across the
border are bringing counterfeit money
they're bringing weapons they're
bringing all kinds of Contraband these
are not the people you want in the
United States you want people who want
to be here and be part of this fabric of
America and one more Point guys I'm
sorry I don't mean to hijack this
segment but don't be scared talking
about this topic the liberal media knows
exactly why the left is letting this
atrocity go on at the border and you
know why this is about abusing and using
migrants for what the left perceives to
be political power they are so afraid of
you talking about this there there let
me repeat their love affair with what
they call replacement theory that if you
mention it mention them talking about it
they accuse you of being a racist for
highlighting them talking about I I
printed this up I had my wife print this
this is a New York Times op-ed right
here literally titled we can replace
them in the New York Times They are
obsessed with this idea of using and
abusing migrants for what they they call
demographic Destiny and if you doubt me
one bit you should always fact check go
online put in Dick Durbin Joaquin Castro
demographic Destiny and listen to the
way they talk about these migrants to
this country as if they are tools for
their political power it's disgusting
thanks for telling the truth Dan I just
think radical truth-telling is the only
way out of what the mess we're in thank
you and don't be cows it's true this all
the time and peoples gets oh my gosh you
know these goofballs at mediaite or
whatever they said don't talk about it
you know what I flip these people a
double barrel middle finger every time
I'm not talking about it I'm talking
about you talking about it and I just
backed it up just go look at the New
York Times and read it it's called we
can replace them what else do you need
me to say yeah and meanwhile they're
treated it's conspiracy it's conspiracy
yeah they're treating the children
coming across as assembly lines
um it's disgusting it's disgusting it's
disgusting Rachel and these are these
people these are human beings and they
deserve far better than this they don't
deserve to be treated like Pawns in some
big political game for your disgusting
tyrannical political goals it's gross
and no one's going to lecture me by the
way about immigration or you Rachel
either my wife came here the right way
went through the entire process you can
have a hard pass on lectures from Samuel
and Media Matters smoking a bowl in his
mama's basement in between watching porn
sessions I don't need your lectures on
what immigration is like you can plant a
big wet one on my rump okay I've been
through it You Don't Know Jack squat go
back to your you know 14th century
women's studies class on the quad in
college and you know read about in a
book what your buddy told you about we
lived through it
no no Dan it's conspiracy to read
someone's words back to them that's
that's now conspiracy yeah
uh but hey Dan you have some new words
out you got a new book it's on pre-order
now I love the title you have to tell us
about it the gift of failure
thank you so much just briefly it's
available for pre-order wherever you get
your books uh I I said I'd never write a
book again uh but I did because I was I
was coming out after Rumble went public
it was our first successful parallel
economy story with uh Rumble it's funny
I was leaving it a whole bunch of people
were liberals of course attacking me on
Twitter about how but a loser I was
because I lost for office and and all
this other stuff and I thought to myself
guys we just bought a company public at
three billion dollar evaluation that's
lose it I said bring on the losing we
love this it's some great losing and
then I got to thinking I said you know
everybody writes books about how great
they are and all their successes 12
steps stand by Gino's wonderful I said
to my wife I'm not going to write that
book I'm going to write a book about
everything I screwed up it's raw it's
embarrassing at times but it's stories
about the Secret Service things I
screwed up but the NYPD things I screwed
up uh it just it really was a it's it's
I'm really proud of this I mean it we
are our failures we're marked more by
our failures and what we've done after
them than we are by our successes and I
think that's the theme of the book and I
hope everybody likes it I can't wait to
read it will Pete and I talk a lot about
how our own failures have led us to
where we're at so it's a gift it is it
truly is if you can see it when you
handle it right that's right if you
handle it right precisely the world is
littered with super smart people who are
very talented good looking and athletic
who could never handle failure will in
the sports base you could probably tell
the hundred stories about this right now
all right Dan tell us what no doubt what
you have um on the show tonight
we have an exclusive finally like our
first great exclusive one on filter with
Matt taibi about getting attacked up on
Capitol Hill will had the best tweet
ever about that by the way Democrats
attacking a Democrat journalists about
censoring Democrat tweets that was
awesome the tahimi we have Anna Paulina
Luna Jack Carr and I have a fiery
rebuttal with Jose aristimuno a Democrat
it was a good sport but I pin him down
on hey what's the fair share can you
give me a number you Democrats keep
talking about how much more do I owe you
guys and he actually I get him to argue
for a tax cut a Democrat he doesn't even
know it so it's glorious to watch check
that out and Pete's on of course as well
with hot takes so it's good stuff
congrats on the book Dan it's awesome
thank you guys absolutely appreciate it
and thanks to the team for letting me uh
promote that I deeply appreciate it it
means a lot you guys the gift of failure
yeah I love it you got to come on my
podcast and promote it oh yeah let's do
it let's I actually done all right
thanks Dan to you guys never miss
unfiltered I'm Steve I'm Brian Kilmeade
and I'm Ainsley Earhart and click here
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page to catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis